our friend Kyle kolinsky / secular talk
covered a really interesting Pew study
about why America's non-believers left
their religion or don't have a religion
and let's first listen to Kyle's
commentary and then I've got some
thoughts Pew Research decided to ask
people why they left religion and the
results are interesting so it says half
of nuns NO NES left childhood faith over
lack of belief one in five cite dislike
of organized religion some of the more
specific numbers here we're mostly going
to be focusing on the stuff on the left
that's in bold so the percentage of
people who left simply because they said
look I don't believe like I don't
believe I don't think religion is true I
don't think it's correct so I'm not
religious 49 percent say yeah I just
don't believe so that's their reasoning
hey why do you call yourself a nun and
know any like as I'm not affiliated with
religion think I just don't believe I
don't think it's true
twenty percent say I actively dislike
organized religion so that's the second
category there the it's behind don't
believe in terms of how many people said
it then eighteen percent said their
religiously unsure undecided so that's
the people who go oh why am I not
affiliated with any religion I don't
know I don't know I'm just not sure if I
believe and I don't know I just don't
know and then you have people who are
inactive believers so they're part of
the nun category that's ten percent
they're part of the nun category but
they say yeah I just really don't go to
services and I don't know I don't
actively practice it so I guess I'm not
really religious so there's your
breakdown there forty nine percent say I
don't believe I don't think it's true
twenty percent say I actively dislike
organized religion eighteen percent say
I'm I'm religiously unsure undecided I
don't know
and ten percent are just inactive
believers this is also interesting I'm
going to give you the percentage real
quick of
non-believers who describe themselves as
atheist agnostic or and nothing in
particular 82% describe themselves as
atheist 63% also describe themselves as
agnostic and 37% say there's just
nothing in particular and let me just
give you some examples real quick of why
people say they're unaffiliated I'll
give you the direct quotes for the
people who said look I just don't
believe here's what they said
learning about evolution when I went
away to college that's what made this
person non-religious another person said
to many Christians doing unchristian
like things
another said religion is the opiate of
the people I believed stole that from
Karl Marx another person said rational
thought makes religion go out the window
another said lack of any sort of
scientific or specific evidence of a
creator
I just realized somewhere along the line
that I didn't really believe it I'm
doing a lot more learning studying and
kind of making decisions myself rather
than listening to someone else
so those are examples of people who said
I just don't believe um
and then for people who dislike
organized religion I'll give you just a
few of these real quick one person said
I see organized religious groups as more
divisive than uniting another person
said the clergy sex abuse scandal that's
why they dislike organized religion and
another person said the Church's
teachings on homosexuality so
interesting stuff it's a growing
population for sure in the US and
probably the West more generally
speaking and I think that's largely a
good thing so there you have it the
beliefs of non-believers and why they
came to that conclusion the study
actually goes even further it digs into
some of the specific reasons why people
either don't believe or dislike
organized religion which Kyle mentioned
there and some of these are really
interesting for example learning
evolution when going to college was
cited as a reason why someone stopped
believing rational thought learning
critical thinking has made people stop
believing and move away from religion
realizing that there is not specific
scientific evidence of a creator as
their religion might explain or suggest
realizing that they never really
believed it and feeling eventually that
they were comfortable saying that under
being religiously unsure or undecided
one quote from the study I don't have a
particular religion because I am
open-minded and I don't think there is
one particular religion that is right or
wrong this is so fascinating to me
because when you look at the influence
that the American right particularly the
Religious Right has tried to have over
curricula in schools they don't want
critical thinking class interestingly if
there had been more critical thinking in
high school rather than college many
non-believers would have moved away from
religion earlier instead of waiting to
get to college when you look at the
specifics of evolution teaching
intelligent design and creationism
alongside teaching evolution that is
something that when not done would much
more quickly get people towards their
non-belief so in order to understand the
religious rights perspective and why
they want what they want when it comes
to well critical thinking what why does
that make any difference you see it in
this study teaching critical thinking
earlier would lead to a more quickly
D religious affine call it what you will
a population that more quickly moves
away from religion that even what we
have now the Religious Right does not
want that and that is why they get
involved at the local level in textbook
selection in the rewriting of class
curricula etc progressives need to
understand that this is yet another one
of the many ways in which you've got to
do more than just oppose Donald Trump
there are real ways here to move the
country to the left and education really
is preventing right-wing education
reform is one of them